Asalam alaikum.
I am Maria Deiana.
Okay. Okay. I am Maria Deiana. I am
>> okay.
>> Profession.
>> Uh
my name is Maria Deiana. I am Muaf. Uh
and I start learn Islam since uh 2014
by your logical religion. No.
Alhamdulillah.
I have real late about what your speech
tonight
and there is no hesitation that Islam is
the brilliant religion. So
if there is some rules in Islam
or there is uh some rule in Islam that
still make me confused, it's just
because I'm not brilliant enough. I know
it. But Dr. the second night. Beside all
that, I need your help to make me
realize how wonderful the heaven because
I heard that in Jenna there is no pain,
there is no worry, there is no rule,
there is no disappoint. So how
>> sister can you speak close to I can hear
some of your words, some I cannot hear.
>> Okay.
>> Can you come closer to the microphone
and speak a bit loudly and slowly?
>> Okay, like this Dr. Zagnay, it's enough.
Uh, can the audio people increase the
volume?
>> Okay.
>> Yes, sister. Loudly and clearly into the
microphone.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Um, Dr. Zakir, I beside all that,
I need your help to make me really how
wonderful the heaven because I heard
that in Jenna there is no pain, there is
no worry, there is no rules, there is no
disappoint. So how we can enjoy with the
happiness without boring while we doing
nothing or effortless because in the he
in this world we know that we need to
pass the pain to feel grateful when the
happiness come. Thank you
>> sister asked the question if I'm not
mistaken she accepted Islam in 2014.
That's what she said. She wants me to
help her to become a better Muslim. She
heard that in Jenna there is no pain,
there is only peace. So how come
there'll be happiness if there's no pain
and there's no peace? The difference
between Jenna and this world is in Jenna
everything is peaceful.
You will feel very happy but always a
person has a desire. So in Jenna the
extra happiness will be you want to see
the vaj of Allah. You want to see the
face of Allah
in Jenna.
Everyone will be peaceful. Everyone will
be happy. But the desire would be that
they want to see the face of Allah. And
always you will not see the face of
Allah. The hadith says okay it will be
there. It will come on Friday. There are
various hadith. So the people in Jenna
would desire to see the face of Allah.
That would be extra happiness
for you. If you want to be a better
believer, my request is you read the
Quran with translation in the language
you understand the best and implement on
it. Inshallah, you'll be closer to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala and there are higher
chances to go to Jenna. Hope that
answers the question.
>> Thank you, Dr. Zakay.